welcome to CBS this morning we expect
this to be a critical week in the
Democratic presidential race with the
focus shifting to South Carolina which
is where our Gail King is in Charleston
the state's largest city ahead of
tomorrow's CBS News democratic debate
and Gail's been down there all weekend
Gail how's it going I was going to say
Anthony's you know I got off the set on
Friday went straight to the airport have
been here ever since
and listen we've spent a lot of time
talking to voters who tell us they're
going to be looking at this debate very
closely because it's five days and
Counting until the big primary and many
of them told us they have not made up
their mind that was a surprise to me and
that's a big deal because we've got
senator Bernie Sanders he had a
commanding victory in Nevada over the
weekend
he's got 40% in the latest count over
Joe Biden at 19 doubling up the number
two position but that that map that
could change dramatically and we
couldn't see a new frontrunner Joe Biden
would certainly hope so with that big
week down in South Carolina Gail it
remains to be seen South Carolina is the
center of the political world this week
seven Democratic candidates will be on
that stage tomorrow night at the Gilyard
Center you can see it behind me it's a
spectacular building gives me goosebumps
as we sit here knowing what's going to
happen there tomorrow night the debate
as you may have heard is co-hosted by
CBS News we're very proud to be part of
this it's the last time that voters will
see the candidates together before
Saturday South Carolina's primary and
the big Super Tuesday showdown next week
so this is a really big deal
our CBS News battleground tracker shows
former Vice President Joe Biden leading
in South Carolina with 28% but that
numbers down 17 points since last
November and Bernie Sanders is closing
in so this is what makes this primary
different this will be the first
significant test of support among black
voters who make up about 60% of the
Democratic electorate in the state it
O'Keefe is here with more on that part
of the story so what can we expect to
hear hello and welcome back to the
campaign trail yeah what can we expect
from the candidates well look as you
said South Carolina has the largest
percentage of african-american voters in
an early primary state Joe Biden has
been leading among them but his support
has fallen 19% with them
since the fall Bernie Sanders won in
Nevada over the weekend when support
from women Latino voters and young
voters my god there are a lot of people
here tonight senator Bernie Sanders
campaign Sunday in the Super Tuesday
state of Texas speaking to crowds of
thousands now I've been hearing you know
the establishment is getting a little
bit nervous about our campaign Sanders
now has the most delegates and votes not
to mention all the momentum something
former Vice President Joe Biden is
hoping to curb this week in South
Carolina the african-american community
in South Carolina can make a judgement
about who the next president of States
is going to be doing well in South
Carolina means winning over the state's
predominantly black voters and Biden's
support has been slipping what I'm
expecting is to make the case to the
people here in South Carolina that they
have an opportunity to essentially
determine who the next president is the
biggest hurdle for moderate Democrats
right now is consolidating enough
support to stop Sanders some Democrats
like South Carolina Congressman Jim
Clyburn are concerned that the senator a
self-described Democratic Socialist will
alienate some voters
this is South Carolina and South
Carolinians are pretty leery about that
title
socialist CBS News has learned that
Clyburn is expected to endorse Biden on
Wednesday and congresswoman Donna
shillelagh a Democrat representing parts
of South Florida is raising concerns
about Sanders his comments about the
late Cuban dictator Fidel Castro on 60
minutes
we're very opposed to the authoritarian
nature of cupid but you know you got
it's unfair to simply say everything is
bad you know when Fidel Castro came into
office you know what he did he had a
massive literacy program is that a bad
thing
even though Fidel Castro did he a lot of
dissidents in prison didn't that's right
and we condemned that now while the
candidates are here today and tomorrow
for the debate they're not going to
spend all week in this state because as
we mentioned there are 14 states holding
contests just eight days from now on
Super Tuesday
they'll be doling out more than 1300
delegates on that day that's why they
want to spend some time trying to find
delegates in other parts of the country
they're not spending time here they sure
are leaving a lot of commercials it's
amazing what you see when you go out of
me
and see all the commercials it's a big
world out there thank you very much Edie